okay I've been talking about this for a
while and it's time we need your help
the david pakman show needs your help we
have launched an indiegogo crowdfunding
campaign you can access it by going to
david pakman.com slash donate this is a
sixty thousand dollar campaign this is
the biggest campaign we've ever done uh
we we need your help I don't know how
else to say it we have some really big
goals this is by far the biggest
potential that we have to fundamentally
grow the influence not just of the david
pakman show november eighth told us this
is way bigger than the david pakman show
this is now about progressive activism
and engagement and at the top of the
list for what we are looking to fund
with this campaign is the creation of a
progressive engagement coordinator I've
spoken to other independent progressive
shows and we have a sort of coalition of
programs which could really benefit from
organization in terms of what campaigns
what initiatives what issues can all of
our audiences work together on in 2017
in 2018 into the 2020 campaign the
census and redistricting there's so much
going on but progressives need to be
engaged low voter turnout in the 2016
election told us that progressives were
not engaged enough lack of organization
at the local and state level by
progressives in many cases tells us that
we are not coordinated and organized
enough so at the top of the list for
this campaign in terms of the goals is
the creation of a real progressive
engagement coordinator now in addition
to that we also have proposals in from a
professional studio design company a
really professional guy came in and took
all sorts of measurements in our studio
and is sort of ready to bring our
production to the next level which uh is
something that has a significant cost
and it relates to another really big
initiative that we are in the middle of
which is we are finalizing we are
working with amazon prime to finalize
the technical requirements for putting
the david pakman show on amazon prime
this is absolutely
ly huge it is not uh uh as big as it
would be to be on netflix but amazon
prime is really really big right now and
putting the david pakman show on there
would be a major accomplishment it is a
big enough project in and of itself that
the technical and staff time
requirements exceed our current
capabilities so that's another aspect in
terms of technical and staff
requirements that we are fundraising for
and then there's some other goals also
which you can check out at david
pakman.com slash donate now this can be
done okay even if you can only donate
two dollars don't think that it's not
worth going to david pakman.com slash
donate and donating the two dollars
those small contributions make a big
difference if anything we learned from
the Bernie Sanders campaign it's that
small contributions from many people
make all the difference in the world so
whether it's two dollars or three
dollars or four dollars whatever you can
contribute don't skip it because you
think it won't make an impact it takes
one minute or at the most if you have an
IndieGoGo account already takes even
less time to make a donation at david
pakman.com slash donate and every
donation of every size is going to help
we've got great perks lined up
everything from david pakman show bumper
stickers to david pakman show t-shirts
to the signed 2017 david pakman show
calendars to the flash drives being back
you'll remember about a year ago we had
a promo where we offer david pakman show
32 gigabyte flash drives and they've not
been available since that is a premium
only available through the crowdfunding
campaign and what i think a lot of
people really are going to be into pat
at the higher levels we have perks that
will allow you to co-host the david
pakman show we've never done this before
and i am fascinated and potentially
horrified but also cautiously optimistic
that that's going to read the lead to
some really cool things and to some
extent you have your choice of stories
too we wouldn't give you free rein that
it would be kind of up to you you would
almost be like co-host and associate
producer for at either a bonus show or a
broadcast show
segment so please do not skip the
donation because you feel like you can't
donate enough to make a difference
whatever you can donate makes a
difference also we have a referral
contest the top 5 referrers of donors
which is tracked by the campaign we'll
get our two hundred ninety nine dollar
perk called the total package for free
okay there's five of those available all
you have to do is go to david pakman.com
slash donate and sort of at the top
right of the campaign page you will see
Twitter and Facebook share buttons when
you use those buttons to share the
campaign our system tracks donations
that come from your referrals and the
top five refers will get the two hundred
ninety nine dollar perk for free we will
ship the stuff to you wherever you are
in the world that'll be the restriction
if you're on another planet I can help
you with the shipping but we will take
care of the shipping costs wherever you
are on planet earth david pakman.com
slash donate if you have questions let
me know if you have perk ideas let me
know let's make this happen today is day
one thanks to some early donors we are
already over the two thousand dollar
mark we've not even started when you
were hearing me talk about this right
now we've not even started this is the
start and we've already raised two of
the sixty thousand dollars we're looking
to raise let's do it with peace and love
as I like to say send me your thoughts
i'm on twitter at d pakman